I had a great time would have been more
fun if we hot boxes things marijuana was
a hot topic on Miley Cyrus's carpool
karaoke segment Tuesday night host James
Corden asked the pop star to rank on a
scale of 1 to 10 how high she was during
memorable milestones wrecking ball video
10 you are hot when you're on the ball
high high as hell yes
via nice actually zero Miley opened up
about that controversial 2013
performance she explained how it
inspired her to change her image I
realized if that many people were gonna
talk about something that I did or
something that I do then I should make
it a good thing and I should make it
something that can change people's lives
rather than be a controversial
conversation that does nothing about
become a fun Halloween costume the pair
drove around la singing classic Miley -
and it's a good thing James was the one
driving here's what happened after Miley
backed her car into a sound trailer on
the set of The Voice I didn't tell
anyone I just left us I did a hit and
run I go until Adam and Blake I'm like
hear knocking what I did last night I
totally wrecked the voice sound Taylor
yeah that was miked already so the sound
I told on myself even though I went
through all the the craziness to not get
busted
[Music]
you
[Music]